i'm bringing this back right because
after that i i realized god was like how
do people die from cows i'm like god
they're like four tons what do you mean
how do people die from cows like so many
people in the suburbs
you can die from cows but you can die
from anything that's like four [ __ ]
tons from any like heavy ass that's why
should that make me look like an idiot
for saying a cow can kill you a cow can
[ __ ] kill you
just because a cow can kill you doesn't
mean that you know probably if you get
killed by a cow you're doing something
stupid right that's just that's just my
opinion right
you'd have to try really [ __ ] hard to
die from a cow most most ways people die
not from stupid ways god as well
believe it or not
i remember i saw a statistic in japan
where it's like more people in japan die
from vending machines and they do shark
attacks oh well okay that makes sense
yeah right how from shaking the vending
machine and landing on you and dying
okay well that's just idiots being
idiots you deserve that if you're sure
that's what i mean it's the same thing
with a cow like you're not gonna be
walking through the [ __ ] paddock and
then suddenly cow's like let me come and
squish you
also very very uh i think they can bite
you at all oh yeah um
if you're strong enough to uh push a
vending machine on yourself yeah why are
you wasting all that talent you know
what i mean like how do you get the
vending machine to fall on you it can't
be easy do you jump on it like why are
people doing this i i don't know
you cannot you have you tried moving a
vending machine it is not easy
like you really have to be committed to
this stupid act like you really are
admitting like all right i'm breaking a
sweat today like this is how i'm going
to take it off the yeezys for this one
that's what i'm saying about dying dying
from cows you know
why why [ __ ] try push like lying
under a cow
or
just go swim in shark-infested waters
apparently i think you you know i think
you have more chance of dying via the
cow honestly um have you ever seen
enough live league videos people [ __ ]
with animals to realize
on facebook or twitter and one gets on
there somehow and you just how i don't
know i'm just happy
yeah you just see like uh you know like
a monkey punching a man or something i
don't know what
he does retweet some of those questions
she just sees [ __ ] and then like people
like [ __ ] around with monkeys and
then the monkey just beats them up
honestly like if i see the live link
logo that's like a i should probably
there is a worrying amount of people who
think that like they can just like do
whatever they want their animals
yeah
but it's normally like like third world
countries and it's like scary because
they're like [ __ ] with like a monkey
and then the monkey beats them up and
you're like well i mean fair enough
family what did you expect yeah you kind
of had the right you know in court i
would i would i would anderson you know
you're like [ __ ] with the smartest
animal yeah like because like i'm very
wary whenever i see anything live
learning because i've seen enough [ __ ]
up [ __ ] on the inside it's also a meme
i've seen people put live league on them
like meme stuff
so now i'm like i'm not sure if it's
meme or not it's it's like playing a
game like reddit 5050 or whatever
that's the only that's the only time
i've seen enough lively tower where i'm
just like yeah no no nothing good comes
out of live sometimes it comes on and
you're like this is intriguing enough
where i don't think i can stop watching
now like the the premise i'm hooked i
don't know man i very quickly pulled
them yeah i'm just like you guys have
more willpower
when i see the premise or the first one
second the video i'm like damn i can't
turn it off now
is that wrong with me i feel like that's
bad i mean
i'm just wired to click bait i don't
know
monkey brain activates right